and happy Halloween everyone my name is
Alex Chisum I am the product manager for
posit Cloud here at posit I really
appreciate you taking the time and
joining us today as we get together for
the fourth installment of posit Cloud
Essentials at this point through the
first three um we've been able to create
accounts set up different workspaces
collaborate on data projects with other
people today we're going to focus on a
lesser known Tool uh that can give you
programmatic access to spefic specific
things within posit cloud and we'll see
some use cases for that as we've defined
what posit cloud is it's essentially a
you know a SAS online platform with with
a certainly a free tier that you can
play around with today uh that is
centered around this notion of space and
within a space you can have projects you
can have collaborators you can have data
connections and you can kind of Monitor
and manage you know who's collaborating
within all across all of these entities
um one thing we haven't talked about
before in detail is this notion of space
member and the role associated with them
so I just wanted to go broadly over this
today because it's going to be important
when we start looking at what this this
package can can do for us in terms of
understanding the analytics and some of
the the member management behind it um
so there are four levels if you were to
create your own space you would be
what's known as an admin and as an admin
you're able to manage users so you can
bring people on you can boot them off
you can set the the role that they're
going to have within this space you also
have the unique ability to archive and
delete that specific space so you can
get rid of it forever and of course as
an admin you're going to have control
over your content and anybody else's
content that's on the system so viewing
and and editing um and the like and then
finally you're going to be able to view
analytics and usage data um based upon
what what people are doing in that
space typically if we're thinking like
in an education um um organization
institution the the instructor would be
the admin in the space and maybe they
bring on someone like a TA and the TA
might often get assigned the role of
moderator which has some of the more
advanced um functionality that the admin
has uh they can control all access and
they can view um usage data so they're
able to see what people put together
they're able to get there and work on it
um and also edit and delete things that
that might need to be cleaned up for
that
space and then the contributor is
typically aligned with this student role
so we might have more of them and they
can view any shared content that the
admin or the moderator or actually other
contributors have made public to that
space um and they're also able to
control their own content so they can
look at something the professor has put
together they can maybe turn that into
their own copy and start doing work and
they can also create random projects to
to start learning uh data science in
that way and then finally a viewer and a
viewer has the least amount of roles by
default um and really all they can do is
view shared content that someone else
has released to that space and if you
think across like all these four user
groups there are different levels of
interaction between everything that's
that's going on within that space so
you've got content visibility we're
going to be able to either see um your
own stuff certainly or other things that
have been shared we need to have some
element of membership management because
we have all these different people with
different um Privileges and permissions
and then underlying all this because we
are a an online platform we have the
ability to tie back what everybody is
doing from a usage point of view uh to
see what content they're engaging with
and how many compute hours have been
used within a given
space so what I want to do today is take
a quick look um to a package that is up
on GitHub that we're going to go through
it's called RS cloud and it's going to
give you the ability to interact with
your posit cloud account um especially
at that space level that we just we just
saw so we'll drop this this link into
the chat for you to play
around and from within this package
we're going to look at two kind of
streams of work that we could do we
could do Space Management and we're
going to look at being able to go out
and like find the spaces that you own be
able to see who's in there be able to
invite people remove people and that's
one of the main benefits here actually
like everything we're going to see today
you can access via the the UI but
sometimes you might have a space whether
you are a university and you've got a
big course of 300 people that are in
there or you're at an organization you
have a bunch of people that are
collaborating on data science project
and you want to bring in a lot of people
at one time or remove a lot of people
you're going to be able to do that
programmatically through some of these
functions and then finally we're going
to take a look at the analytics that
comes from it so this is primarily what
you see on your usage tab but if you've
got a lot of content and a lot of people
and a lot of spaces this makes it easy
to get that into kind of a you know a
data ready format for you to do
subsequent
analysis if you have any questions along
the way please drop them into the chat
um if I don't catch them as I'm going
along um and giving this presentation
we'll be able to get to them at the end
so let's get started I'm going to go in
and switch my tab to posit cloud
great now from here I'm going to use a
free account today um and again if you
don't have an account already go
deposit. Cloud create an account and
you'll be able to to see all the
functionality that that I'm that I'm
demoing today so I'm going to log in
just with Google this is just a free you
know dummy account that we that we set
up and you can see when I arrive in here
that I and Professor Adams I've got a
personal workspace which we've described
in the past right now I don't have any
content in there and you can also see
that I have a stat 250
space um and by clicking on it we can
see everything that's in here so right
away you see you know we have a fair
amount of content to begin with you can
see because I'm on this free account
that it says this space is full so I'm
not able to have more than 10 projects
within this this given space but that's
okay for today uh for our demo it'll
make sense um but you might have a lot
more right you might be teaching a
course for for an entire semester you
might have a lot more students that are
also adding their content to the space
so even though today we're not focusing
specifically on um the features within a
space to help this content management
I'll show just a few things to to help
out one is along the lines of filtering
so you can see we have these 10 pieces
of content I can go and see what type of
content piece this is right now they're
all
projects if I go to access I can be like
well who what what of these are
available to space members and we can
see that all of these six which I
designated as an as an assignment for
each project are now viewable and I can
do basic things like sorting based on
the create date and the name as well the
last thing that I'll show is just how to
create a list so if you have a lot of
content and you want to organize it
maybe a little bit better you can go to
new list and you can type in you know
the name that you want for this list um
and you can make it available for just
for admins and moderators or for anybody
in your space and you can see here I've
grouped those six core assignments into
unit one where we're talking about data
visualization and exploratory analysis
in unit two I've got significant testing
and then in unit three I've got
regression analysis and some machine
learning
Basics so we have content we have our
space we even have members already so
right now I've got myself Professor
Adams and I've got three students
Pugsley go momez and mortia here and you
can see that their level is at that role
of contributor that I mentioned earlier
on that is the typical one we associate
with with students if we're thinking
through an education
example you can refine even further the
permissions for contributors or viewers
depending on what you want to
do and then we also have a usage
tab where you can see at a high level
how many compute hours have been
associated with this space the number of
active m numbers and the the the amount
of active content uh that is within this
period and you can segment this out by
by usage
period And what I want to do through
this RS Cloud package is set up a way
again programmatically uh to get some of
these these data points more quickly and
then to help with those bulk operations
about bringing people in or maybe
booting them out of a space uh without
having to go one by one you know delete
delete
delete so for this because I am using
this free account and I can't add
another project here I'm going to go
ahead and click on my personal workspace
and we'll create a new
project and we'll call this of course
management and we're going to have to do
a few things here uh the first thing
that we're going to want to do is bring
in some packages that we're looking for
including uh RS Cloud which you will not
find on cran but we we're going to be
able to get from GitHub
directly okay so we have our blank
session I'm going to create a new
[Music]
file we're going to call this just RS
Cloud
maybe and I'm just going to type in the
libraries that I know that I'm going to
use for this so I know I'm going to want
the Tidy verse at some point I know I'm
going to want
remotes I'm also going to want use
this and we don't have any of these
because it's the first time that we've
opened this project we haven't created a
template with these packages so I'm
going to go ahead and install all of
this and while that's going in I'll
remind you about you know what is
different maybe from operating an R
studio in your desktop versus in this
environment uh the biggest uh difference
is most likely going to be about how you
can control the resources associated
with your project so if you click on the
gear and then go up to resources you
have the ability to control your your
RAM and your CPU and the amount of
background execution time which means
the amount of time that your session
will stay active if you have uh code
running in the background um this is a
you know a freemium tool I've mentioned
several times you can create a free
account today if you go to a
professional plan or if you're on an
education plan you're going to have a
bigger number a larger level of
entitlements for you to increase things
like RAM and
compute all right so while this is going
in I'm going to go
and copy in some code which is going to
bring in the package we need from RS
cloud in fact why don't I hop over now
to
[Music]
GitHub while that finishing up um so you
can see that the package is here a lot
of these instructions for getting going
are going to be described within the
documentation the main thing we're going
to have to do that's different from how
we typically operate in posa cloud is
we're going to have to first generate um
some credentials for us and then we're
going to store them as an environmental
variable and then we're going use this
to interact specifically with our
account uh through the
package so if I'm back over here now
we're going to see that we can go ahead
and
get RS Cloud
installed now I've got it and let me
make sure because it's saying I don't
have used this let's check for sure if
we don't have it no that is there all
right so we should have everything that
we need right now to to get started uh
so the first thing that we're going to
have to do I mentioned we need to go out
and get credentials to be able to make
this secure connection to our accounts
information to be able to run some of
these uh some of these functions uh for
this there's a function called edit R
environment and when I run this it's
going to open up a new
tab and it's blank and what we have to
do is we have to create credentials and
then bring them in here um to store it
so I'm going to go to my name and I'm
going to rightclick on create
credentials and open this in a new
tab I can see I can see already that I
neglected to to switch tabs on that you
were still looking at GitHub sorry about
that all we did here was bring in uh the
libraries that we're that we're going to
use we brought in RS cloud and then we
ran this command edit our environment
which gave us this blank uh file from
which now we're going to go to a
different screen and grab our
credentials so I went went to my name I
went to credentials I right clicked and
I opened and it brought me
here so you can see right now in this
setting area we have client credentials
and right now we don't have any to use
all you need to do is click on new
credentials and I'll just call this
demo and it's going to give me a set of
credentials I'll delete this after the
workshop we're also on a free account so
there's not much you can do uh with it
U but I'm just going to go ahead and
copy the RS Cloud client ID and the
client secret which is what the package
uses uh to authenticate us to let give
us access essentially to the data we're
working
with so now that we're here I'm going to
hop back share this tab and now we're
back with this blank file I'm going to
go ahead and save that and now we should
have the information we need uh to start
pulling data from our account so I'm
going to close this the other thing I
need to do once I've added those
environmental variables is restart my R
session this will be pretty quick and
now just to make sure we're going to go
out we don't need remotes anymore but
use this in the Tidy versure what we are
looking for and then I also want to
bring in now that we have it Library RS
Cloud perfect so I'll move this to the
top because we don't need it
anymore all right so we've gone out we
have all the libraries we need we've we
got our credentials in there and now we
can start using functions from the RS
Cloud Library uh to start understanding
what our what our environment looks like
so maybe the first one I'll do what is
called my
spaces and there's a function called RS
Cloud space
list and I don't need to pass anything
into this I'm going to go ahead and run
this and it'll take a take a few moments
to come
back and what it's doing is it going out
to to the systems it's saying how many
spaces are associated with my account
that we use those credentials to get
through and we can
see if we look at it we've got five
records that come
back and this might be a little bit
interesting because if you look to my
left of my screen you can see that I
only have one space right now so it's a
little bit curious why these other ones
are coming back and the reasons are
these are spaces that I've either been a
part of as a contributor or ones that I
have either archived um or deleted that
are still in here for which I can see
historic data but looking at here we can
see that stat 250 is the one that we're
interested in and I've got a space ID
associated with us with it so I'm going
to copy that space
ID and now I'm going to go back into
code and I want to be able to start
setting a Target so maybe like the the
target space that we're interested
in and from this I'm going to do RS
Cloud space and pass in that um that
space ID which I think is okay to do as
a numeric variable let's go ahead and
find out perfect so we can see that the
the command worked if I click on target
space and see what this is well we have
sort of we have an object here that's
giving us a high level summary we've got
four users and we've got 10 projects in
total
I can use a function called space info
on my target
space to get a little bit more
information and maybe I'll turn this
into a table so we can see it better
I'll call it space
[Music]
info so we can see a little bit more
about our space right so we've we know
it's private it's protected we have an
account ID associated with it we have
have a long um description which is
actually set up through the UI when the
professor started the the account just
describing what the the course
is we can see that there are no current
default um project settings and we've
got user counts we're able to have up to
five we've got four we've got
limitations so we know a lot about what
we can and can't do within the space and
we can also monitor based upon how much
we currently have in terms of membership
or content you know how close we're
getting to those Li
again this is all on on a free plan and
if you were an educator using um an
instructor plan or a student using a
student plan uh the the rights and the
ability to do more are
present okay so we we see a little bit
more about our
space within a space we've talked a lot
about you know this notion of having
projects or having content um so we can
dig into what content is available again
by taking that Target space that we
created that object and now we're just
going to say space project
list and if I run Space Project
list you can see that we have a we have
these 10 projects that we
mentioned again just so it's easier to
see for everyone I'll go ahead and make
this U into a data
frame or I'll store this into a data
frame and I'll click on it and we can
see that we have first who is the name
associated with the project so we had
everything that that me the Professor
put together and then we had students in
the class who went ahead and made copies
of those and now we see that they have
their own sort of Standalone copies from
this we can tell the last time that they
were updated the last time what what
type of project that that it is um we
have more information on the metadata
behind the name and the description and
the like so a quick way to see you know
what projects you have and imagine if
you had again many spaces and many many
students the ability to go through and
do this for each one one of your spaces
and see kind of like a comprehensive
view of like of usage um and engagement
I think is a useful um
benefit Okay so we've gone through the
Space Project list um let's look then at
membership so if I go once again
starting with my target
space and I pass to that space member
list I can see that there are
four unique
records for Unique users including
myself and then I've got student one two
and three and I can get whatever
information is in the system about them
you know first name last name when they
joined um and all that so we already
knew that these four people were here we
we saw that um from our initial member
list one thing you might want to be able
to do is programmatically invite people
to this specific space
and for this one I'm going to take
Target space I'm going to say
space member
ad and now I'm going to pass through an
email
address and there other options that we
could add to add to this let me show you
what those look
like so this is an invite user
function we can go through and we can
put in one or I'll show you the way to
bring in multiple users in a few seconds
you can also change the this the default
email message that is going out to
people and you can change the role that
you want the person who who is invited
to be able to
get and if I enroll this person now or
if I invite this
person I'm going to go ahead and send
that
out you can see we didn't get any error
messages so what it did was it sent out
an email to this email address asking
them to join this space
you can actually
see who's still waiting and like how
many imitations you might have out there
by looking at the space invitation list
function so if I run this it would have
been empty a few moments ago but now I
can see that I have one record with this
a unique ID to a specific person um that
is still
outstanding so I'm going to hop off
screen now for a second and I'm going to
find
that
invitation in my other
account okay I got the invitation I'm
now following it in deposit
Cloud all right and I'm in over there so
now if I run this same command space
invitation list it returns no
invitations found because the invitation
was out it was accepted by this new user
and they were brought in into the space
and if I were to run again space member
list which initially had four people now
you can see that we have five people
that are within this space including our
new person uh student number
four if I were to
go to my
workspace oh sorry to course space I'm
going to open this in a new tab I'm
going to follow it over and share this
tab now we're back within our course
space for stat
250 if I click on membership you can
again see that we have this new person
student number four her name is
Wednesday uh she's also a contributor
and we can see that you know our class
has grown based upon what we did from
the command line or from from
code okay so we're back now in our
course management project we've just
gone out and we invited people uh the
last thing that I want to show you is
how you can understand who's doing what
within your space um from from
analytics so the way to do this is to
click Again On Target space as as where
we're starting we're going to go out and
say space member
usage and running space member usage you
can see in the console that it only
returns one row it gives us the total
compute time the number of active
accounts the number of active users the
number of active projects um but it's
not giving us anything at that user
level if you want more specifics you're
going to again do Target
space space member
usage and then I need to pass a few more
variables in here so I'm going to do a
filters I'm going to say
list Group
by I'm going to group it by user ID and
then I also need to tell it how long we
want this this usage data to come from
so if you remember or maybe you don't
remember I'll show show it to you in a
second again I'm going to say right now
I want it from seven
days so it's going to go back to my
space it's going to say group Everybody
by their user ID and return analytics
data specifically for the last seven
days and we can see that I've messed up
something
here uh the from is still within the
filters called this should work there we
go and we can see now again within our
one space all the five people three of
them have compute hours associated with
them if you looked at looked deeper into
the columns here you would also see the
number of like active uh content items
and you can see specifically uh what's
uh what each person is doing so our two
of our people haven't even come in and
done any compute at all mortia and
Wednesday
so we've done a fair amount here let me
hop over keeping this open I'm going to
hop to a different
tab I'm going to tie back that usage
data we just looked like looked at and
you can see it here kind of like in the
UI form where you have a less a little
bit less control over what period we're
looking at in terms of usage so one
thing that RS Cloud gives you is a more
refined kind of time Horizon for what
you want those analytics periods to look
like here we just show you a usage
period or calendar month and then you
can pick a specific day um but either
way within this space you can see kind
of what we saw in that data frame that
came from RS Cloud you know these
specific people and then if I went to
pugly and I looked at the content that
they have you can see that here the the
total hours that they used so far in
this
period and you can see it broken down by
content item as
well now the last thing that I'll show
before we get into Q&A um is our members
ship again so let's think about it's
like the end of a maybe a Consulting
project with a bunch of people um or
maybe it's the end of the semester and
you you know your students you no longer
need them in the space for for whatever
reason know you could go through here
and delete everybody or remove them um
but that could be timec consuming if
you're dealing with a lot of students uh
so the last thing we'll look at here I
believe I can also kick out the person
we just added so let's do Target
space I'm going to say space member
remove
and I'll put through the same email of
the person we
invited oh and I need a Content
action probably a good idea to go to the
help function on this
right so it's looking for a space which
we're passing through the user which I
put in and then a Content action this is
saying if this user has anything
specifically within the space what do
you want to do with it I'm just going to
move it to trash if it's there at this
moment there's nothing there there but
let's go
ahead it's going to give you a prompt to
say are you really sure you want to
remove this this member I'm going to say
yes so we we did all this I think there
was a lag on on the screen again my
apologies for that um all we've done
here is we've added a new function space
member remove passed through the email
address and we had to put through a
Content action saying well what do you
want to do when you remove this specific
user from the space what do you want to
happen with all the content for this
person and we're going to send it to the
trash the command line uh prompt us to
say are you sure you want to remove
member 12244 Etc I said yes we removed
that person and now if I go back over to
the user
Tab and refresh this
page you can see that Wednesday is no
longer a student or a member of the stat
250 space held by Professor Adams
so I think we're almost ready for Q&A I
do want to show one more thing uh that
that I skipped over a few moments ago so
the last thing that I'll I'll share back
within the course management one is well
what if you wanted to invite many people
to your
space and what the function requires is
that you have a data frame uh to be able
to do this so what what we can do is we
can bring over we can create a new data
frame let's say
new users and maybe you're pulling this
from a course list that your University
provided you email 1@gmail.com
email
2@gmail.com
so we can go ahead and we have our new
users and then what we're going to want
to be able to do is bring in a bunch of
them by doing
this so we're going to turn this into a
new students tibble
we have what's called our user email
it's going to be equal to
users so if I pull up right now new
students now you could imagine a
spreadsheet or a CSV file that you
brought in once you have that list all
you have to do is pass it through and
it'll go through take those two email
addresses send out those emails again
both people will receive an invitation
you can track their invitation through
that view uh space invitation function
that we looked at earlier and then
you're going to be able to tell you know
who has been invited and who is still
waiting to
join so I think with that I'm G to hop
back in and see if I can
see any questions coming in and today
once again we have Hannah here who's
going to help coordinate the the Q&A
session hey everyone thanks Alex um so
just a reminder that we've set aside
time for Q&A so if you have any there
still time to either drop them in the
YouTube chat or we have the slido link
that was shared um and I'll share it on
the screen now we don't have any
questions yet so I'll just use the space
as a a reminder that we host these every
month on the last Tuesday of the month
um and you can add the vents to your
calendar uh with the link that I'll
share in the chat in just a second so
we'll wait a couple minutes if any
questions come in um if not Alex you've
covered every question there could be
well I guess I guess so and you you we
will share with you the link uh to the
GitHub repo uh you can also dig into the
functions there but pretty much
everything that we shared um was coming
straight
from what you're able to do uh within
within these functions um so both on the
Space Management side the analytic side
um and it's not that the vast majority
of this functionality can't be accessed
from the UI but we find that some
teachers especially like the efficiency
of being able to do it through the
command line when they're setting up and
when they're closing down their courses
at the end of a semester and speaking of
of Education uh next month our topic is
going to be kind of like educational use
cases to see you know what are the most
effective and efficient ways that
instructors can kind of bring students
into posit Cloud to teach you know short
or long uh term courses um a lot of it
applies also to corporate training and
individuals setting up sort of like data
workshops and bringing people into a
unified space one of the main benefits
of course is that you don't need to deal
with everybody being on their desktop
trying to set up and align you know
their their IDE environments you're able
to do it in one place uh with templates
to help you out um and a stable server
environment provided by by posa
Cloud
awesome so no questions yet so I'll give
it a couple more seconds but if they're
aren't any questions for today we can
wrap up early uh and give a little bit
of time back but also another reminder
is that all the past posit Cloud
essential events are in a YouTube
playlist all together so you can watch
them at any time uh this is the fourth
installment so be sure to check back on
the the last month's
episodes
cool so I guess uh we did have a
question come in so I can ask that now
uh someone ask can a removed user's
content also be archived with the
command that was
demonstrated yes you've got four
different options that it was pulling
from let's see you can archive or
trash and then they can take it with
them so archive trash I think two
options come from that natively if you
go to the package and you look at the
help for the function that is space
member remove you'll be able to see all
the full options there
awesome we had another question um Alex
asked how does web integration work for
instance if each student must make a
Blog with independent examples can I
integrate with blog
down that's an interesting question when
you say integrate with blog data are
you're trying to get people to publish
specific things within posit
cloud and if we can't have a an easy
back and forth here I'm happy to to jump
on a a call or an email conversation
with you as
well yes and while we're waiting for
Alex Oh Alex got back to us so email
later would be great okay
you yeah alex. Chism
it.co awesome and then um follow-up
question from Robert he asked what is
the difference between archive and take
it with them an archive will go within
the spaces archive directory directory a
take it with them will bring it to their
personal
workspace
Okay so we've run through the questions
for today so thank you all so much for
joining thank you Alex for walking us
through it and um we'll see you next
month for another episode of posit Cloud
Essentials thank you all for joining in
your questions yeah thanks Anna thanks
everybody